derrière ses lunettes noires Alona
répète les gestes et les manœuvres
militaires à 35 ans c'est ukrainienne
s'est engagée dans l'armée pour défendre
son pays avec plusieurs autres
concitoyens elle est formée ici à Tolède
c'est très
gentil mais des années à être assimilé
dit que je n'en peux plus mais les
instructeurs sont tellement bons et nous
montrent qu'on peut faire bien plus que
l'on ne pense tout est dans notre tête
à l'approche de l'anniversaire de
l'invasion russe beaucoup redoutent une
attaque majeure de Moscou dans les
prochains jours mais leur motivation
reste intacte
leur développement et leur apprentissage
et spectaculaire leur motivation permet
d'importants progrès
augmentera leur chance de survie
ici en Espagne 400 Ukrainiens sont
formés tous les deux mois des
entraînements disponibles aussi dans 24
autres pays de l'Union européenne les
alliés occidentaux mènent par ailleurs
des formations bilatérales des
équipements militaires spécifiques qu'il
fournissent au pays Bruxelles c'était
engagé à former 15000 soldats Ukrainiens
d'ici la fin de l'année un chiffre
finalement revu à la hausse
on a doublé le nombre de soldats que la
mission va former jusqu'au 30 000 dans
le même délai mais deux fois plus et en
plus c'est une mission va aussi
s'occuper de l'entraînement de sorte de
tripulations des chars léopards qui vont
être
donnés
les alliés de Kiev dont l'Allemagne le
Royaume-Uni ou encore les États-Unis se
sont engagés à lui fournir 120 à 140
chars lourds à cela s'ajoutent l'aide
financière européenne depuis février
dernier les pays membres ont donné au
total 3 milliards 600 millions d'euros à
l'Ukraine dans le cadre de la facilité
européenne pour la paix